that's Kanye's fault because like if you
have children with a ratchet woman
you're gonna have a ratchet child like
you should pick a woman who you want
your daughter to become like I will pick
a man who I want my sons to become if
you have a daughter with Kim Kardashian
your daughter's going to end up like Kim
Kardashian and everybody commented like
coming from a woman who doesn't have
children what are you talking about give
me a minute number two how do you need
to have children to know that I don't
understand how you can just disagree
with me don't you want to pick a quality
individual like why would you marry a
woman who became famous from a sex tape
like how is that controversial